building self-driving car
the dream of my life and I've dedicated
more than 10 years to it if we can build
a safer car we would save a lot of lives
but on top of it it's transformational
just imagine instead of owning a car you
have a little phone and you're summon
occur an empty car comes to you years
jump in and lets you go somewhere and
when you don't need anymore
it disappears there is an enormous
market for self-driving car engineers
lots and lots of companies that you
wouldn't suspect have ended that feed
and are massively hiring I challenge
everybody here to be part of this we're
launching a Udacity a nano degree
program called self-driving car so that
everyone in the world can become a
self-driving car engineer
you
welcome my name is sebastian van welcome
to the fourth in a series of audacity
talks i have the unbelievable pleasure
to have a great artist a great
technologists and the super creative
person here instead of a with me eric
Tinnell great to be here thanks for
having me it's great having you Eric
runs or is a chief creative officer for
company called baobab studios formerly
known from DreamWorks and are you a a
creative a technologist a Content person
a cook or a comedian
I basically been a Content person that's
where my career is skewed I mean I
started back in computer animation in
the tight in the days when everybody had
to do some coding but coding is behind
me and now it's all about storytelling
coding is behind you but you're very
well known for a whole bunch of crew
that's right like little bunnies coming
invaders and Madagascar mm-hmm you have
an announcement to make I yeah yeah in
fact invasion which is our first short
which features this little bunny that we
we haven't quite decided the name but I
think I'm just gonna say that her name
is Zoey Zoey ah yeah we had a moat
around the office in Zoey 1 and the
invasion piece which has been out there
in kind of sneak peek form its final
version with Ethan Hawke doing the
narration is going to be released
tomorrow on the oculus headset as well
as the gear VR so for us to find the
pups of champagne tomorrow at the office
and that's pretty excited yeah we have
invited
Erik because he's unbelievably creative
and I mean big admirer of his work and
we have great pleasure having you here
but also because V at Udacity are
launching a virtual reality nanodegree
and there's a parent shift I think and I
want to ask you in a second about this
between the classical 2d movie and then
we hit the 3d movie kinda off didn't
really work that well but somewhat but
now we're going to have the movie ray do
you know where to look like if you look
in the wrong direction you might
actually miss the story the VR movie in
a fully immersed movie
but why do we do this and why is fired
about this well what got me excited
about virtual reality was so when I put
my first headset on and it was the gear
VR which works with the phone so it
wasn't even the high-tech one but it's
one of those things and you've probably
heard it before but until you put one on
you don't really know what people are
talking about but as soon as I put one
on I knew this was the next thing and I
needed to find a way to get involved in
it yeah just got my oculus rift
yesterday and it almost this is the
first meeting this morning which is
sitting there minecraft looking around
different story but so do you think in
in 20 years you all are gonna sit around
in cinemas and take these things and
look in random directions what I think
is gonna happen I don't know what's
gonna happen in 20 years well 20 years
is the singularity I think like could
2045 so I thought exists a bar but
that's before they go away they're
benign yes before we go away well you
know it's hard to predict because
technology tends to move faster and
faster and who knows where we'll be I
mean I would not be surprised if we had
the equivalent of the holodeck in in 20
years the technology is already
improving and it's gonna get better and
better
headsets now I think we'll be laughing a
little bit about the people with the
bricks on their faces you know that
stuff is gonna go away and everything
okay so yeah yeah and very short lived
in the real world I think because the
technology I think will and just improve
in leaps and bounds
and it's hard to predict but in my
lifetime I'm sure that there'll be a
holodeck for everybody
nice so when when new media introduced
like we move from say theater to film
the first full feature film were like
these literal shots of a screen of a of
a theatre play with curtains and
everything and people hadn't quite
discovered you can move the camera or
you can compose a movie out of multiple
pieces or special effects and other
stuff what's going to happen in VR
movies they'll be different from regular
movies well it really is a different
medium it's not just an extension
cinema and you know that when you put a
heads on and you get into this immersive
world that not only engages your
intellect and your emotions but like
engages your reptile brain you know
there are things like you you put me on
the edge of a building and virtual
reality and I'm afraid of heights not
only is it gonna be difficult for me to
look down but there is no way I can
force my leg to take a step forward even
though I know there's gonna be another
carpet and tile beneath my feet I cannot
do it it just it it's very very
immersive in that way and so it's a very
different experience but what I'm
excited about is just like film and
theatre and literature all for the most
part try to focus on having a great
story and telling it well with
characters that we can fall in love with
they do it in very different ways and
they have very different tool sets and
so I think that there's a huge potential
for virtual reality to do some of the
same things that cinema and theater can
do in the way that they engage the human
emotional response and make you cry and
make you laugh and make you care about
characters and I think in VR we have the
potential to do that in a way that's
more profound than any other medium but
to do that we have a very different
toolkit just like cinema has their
different toolkit then then books are
theatres and now is the time and we're
discovering what are the tools in that
black box that we haven't discovered yet
and there's a big job ahead of us
figuring that out yes nobody knows right
it strikes me as as really tricky
because I might look in a direction and
I might miss the scene because I wrote
somewhere else and how do you focus
people's attention are you working this
yeah absolutely that's a huge
consideration for us particularly
because we're often not waiting for we
don't want to wait for the viewer we
want the viewer to be looking where we
want them to look when we want them to
look there and yet have it feel like
it's their free choice it is their free
choice but do things that we whatever we
can do to attract them because for a
storyteller one of the things that's
really important is like rhythm and
pacing and ultimately structure yeah
it's one of the things that end in games
well I love video games computer games
gaming in VR is like a match made in
heaven that's that's gonna be huge but
the one thing that games for me at least
I've always struggled with is like they
have some story they're building up to
some cathartic moment and then you stop
and you kill zombies and make the viewer
choice goddamnit so you can influence
the story about you rather have a
slavery should you focus on what's good
you know for me it's hard enough to tell
a good story anyway you know takes a lot
of work and a lot of effort and so the
idea of like having layer multiple
branching stories that's when the
quality starts to really take a nosedive
so at bail Babs studios what we're
trying to do is find the tools that we
can use to have a great story and tell
it well and have characters that
audiences fall in love with and do it in
the context where the viewer is a part
of the story where they feel like
they're right there where they're
motivated to take action but action that
helps take the story forward in a real
specific way in a way that we've sort of
pre designed for the deals great my
family I love your past movies I can't
wait until tomorrow to see invasion and
I recommend everybody else to really
check it out let me go back in time so
you were born in Kansas yes what are you
doing Kansas you know is it Harriet it's
just driving through in the streets at
like letters names because like a street
B Street C Street yeah well I I grew up
in Prairie Village Kansas school all
places it's actually a suburb of Kansas
City and it's very much like a suburb
you find anywhere in the country and you
know I think the one thing that you
don't really have a lot of in Kansas is
a lot of at least when I was growing up
is a lot of examples of things that you
can do that are outside of the norm you
know there's not a lot of startups in
Kansas City compared to say although I'm
sure there are a lot more now than there
were when I was there you know you think
well I'm gonna be in business I'm gonna
be a doctor I'm gonna be a lawyer but
you don't necessarily like a new pizza
shop yeah exactly but you don't think of
things like I'm going to be a VR content
creator or even I'm gonna be a filmmaker
you have to have a real sort of
far-reaching vision or a farther
reaching vision than you do if you're
living in areas where there's all that
kind of stuff going on so I didn't have
any idea that I'd be doing this when I
was back there I'm went to college to
become a doctor Oh a doctor I'm a doctor
medical doctor and then that slowly
changed when I realized that I can't
just do a profession because I tend to
get good grades in it you know I didn't
I realize I didn't love it especially
when I got the organic chemistry my
grades started started at tumble but I
ended up getting a degree in broadcast
journalism you think it's an undergrad
and then you were the funniest man on
the planet for a while oh I don't know
Oh in junior high don't know where you
found that out junior high I miss or
voted mr. mr. humor I don't even
remember when those days were like two
people know what for but I was really
interested in the imagery that we were
using in broadcast journalism and all of
my classmates were interested in being
on on TV and being the guy and that's
the news yeah and so I had to go to the
film school to find people that knew
about that it could teach me that and
then by the time I graduated with my
journalism degree I wanted to go on and
become an avant-garde filmmaker and live
in a mud hut my whole life and see for a
while thankfully I did construction and
waited tables for about five years until
I had enough material together to apply
to art school I see yes he and
eventually made it to a dream box I
guess yeah how did that happen well I I
started the experimental animation at
Cal arts as a as a master's degree and
at that time computers were experimental
but because of my science background I
was very interested in that and
programming didn't scare me and it was
no chemistry involved okay which is some
other art form and then when I got out
of school I to get an internship at
Pacific data images which in 1991 was
the oldest computer animation company in
existence and and worked there for a few
years and eventually DreamWorks
partnered with Pacific data images to
create their first actually their first
feature animated film that came out of
DreamWorks and I was you know selected
to direct the film along with my part
Tim Johnson I know your PDR better petia
veteran we didn't deserve the job but
nobody else had directed a
computer-animated film except John
Lasseter and he was busy so we lucked
into that job and I've been doing it for
twenty times and you love storytelling I
am no I know I can't ask you to act a
script that you haven't disclosed to the
public yet but you also do a special
role or drop in acting on scripts right
do it the special job in acting scripts
for you become all the character at the
same time well you know it's important
as a director to be able to communicate
a performance so yeah you do sometimes
act out both physically and verbally
like what characters need to do in a
script the facial performance and it's a
big part of communicating with animators
it's also a big part of when we're going
and pitching our ideas to people that
might potentially get involved in one
way or the other
to be able to sit with a group of people
and tell a story in a way that's
compelling and can help them visualize
that story enough that they want to get
involved even though all we have is men
like telling the story basically it's
just it's it's a it's something that
takes a lot of practice and for me at
least it does and I spend hours and
hours practicing my pitches so that when
I get into a room full of people that I
don't know that it's relatively natural
that it is good I think there's a lesson
in fall of students that when I have
jobs practice your interviews and just
go walk up and down and speak to
yourself makes a huge difference I'm
just sit in front of a paper exactly I
know I heard
yo-yo ma was on the radio no famous
cellist yeah the great cellist and and
somebody a girl in the audience young
girl raised her hand and said you know
I'm a music student he said oh that's
fantastic and she said but you know I
can't wait till I'm like you and he said
what do you mean well you know now that
you're so amazing and so and so
accomplished you just don't have to
practice anymore and he said actually I
practice five hours a day and if I don't
I start to get bad really
and so anybody that makes things look
effortless and in the arts is only doing
it because they I can tell you I mean as
a formally tenured professor you get to
a certain trellis we just don't have to
practice anymore you can happily wait
till I vow it but it's true for
everybody else we have to practice yeah
I have questions power students I'll
before with this van ask question but I
want to ask so you created a movie
studio a movie studio not in Los Angeles
on Burbank or Hollywood but in Silicon
Valley
why well for one we're not making movies
we're making virtual reality experiences
and there's a lot of people up in this
area that know how to do feature film
computer animated films because places
like Pixar and ILM and and doesn't
DreamWorks and there's a lot of people
that know how to do real-time rendering
which is a big part of what VR can be
you know is running you know on a big
computer and getting those images out 11
frames I'm sorry one frame every 11
milliseconds twice for each eye and if
so if you want to get that quality of a
feature film and you want to render
those frames you know that quickly you
need a lot of really specialized
technical talent as well so for us it
makes it makes a great deal of sense and
I don't think it really matters where
you are certainly right now as long as
you've got the right mix of you know
business and creative skill and
technical skill and we just found that
we had that up here so many of us
students will be technical and our VR
nano degree that's going to launch soon
we're teaching the skills of the trade
but from your perspective if there's
things that people should focus on this
cover but it might be big open questions
and in virtuality
experiences well you know even though I
say we want to have a kind of a linear
story and tell it with a certain rhythm
and structure interactivity is still
really critical and you know that the
phones that we have are actually pretty
powerful you know when you consider
they're about as powerful as a
Playstation one but again for a great
supercomputer yeah exactly
um it's still really really hard you
know to do anything in real time on a
phone and so you have to make creative
choices and then you also have to make
technical choices about you know how do
you what kind of interactivity can you
get in how much can you pump through
that skinny little pipe but those are
the kinds of things that are gonna
really bring the audience in and I
underestimated how powerful some of the
interactive components really could be
you know this word empathy gets passed
around in the VR world and like this is
that this is the medium of empathy and I
was kind of skeptical but then when we
did our little short where this little
buddy hops out of the trees and and hot
and spots you across this frozen lake
and hops over to you and looks you in
the eye and makes eye contact people
really responded to that in a in in an
emotional powerful way and it's I think
it's simply because this is a character
that recognizes that you are in her
world and actually reacts and responds
to that fact and you just don't really
get it at that level and pretty much any
other medium and people were just
delighted by that and when the little
guy like suddenly starts wanting to play
with you people would jump around and
mimic her her body language and so you
see the first set of Exodus it was a
point where the bunny like runs and
hides behind you and people were some
people described and there hi there
she's hiding from these aliens that are
pointing their weapons at you and you're
almost like working as as a shield for
her and a lot of people said I just felt
this weird surge of like I wanted to
protect the bunny or one guy said you
know I wanted to watch the aliens but I
knew the bunny was behind me and I could
feel her presence even though I know I
was standing in your office it's like I
could feel her breath on the back of my
neck and you put the audience straight
into the sand so there's just some
really powerful things that you can do
and the more interactive the characters
can be with the viewer the more you
they'll suspend their disbelief and
accept the fact that they're a part of
that it's like one thing to invent know
is it bodysuit that shakes and breathes
at you as you as you watch for these
movies yeah and experiences but there's
tons of stuff for technically
I mean there are no vor authoring tools
right now
somebody's gonna write this stuff that
eventually every VR studio will probably
want to use because it'll help them so
much
you know there's pipelines there's just
a lot of tech map challenges out there
yeah it's just a wonderful time to be
here today
and I want to remind all of our students
I mean the things that we take for
granted today like the cell phone is not
even 10 years old Twitter on Facebook
just about 10 years and and suffering
cars have just been invented recently
and so in 10 years time you might all be
deeply immersed as some companies that
have see through this place they can see
stuff and then years mix with real
reality called augmented reality a lot
of opportunities a lot of dropsy and
certain valley so what I ask is a
question I'm gonna start with Maria and
here's a very simple question and I just
pass it on how did the idea of
virtuality animation really start what's
the historical origin well it's been
around for a long time at PD I back in
the early 90s there were a couple of the
technical guys that actually rigged a
couple of giant at that time they were
the smallest monitor see heavy headset
me you would sit in its wheelchair they
strapped a Silicon Graphics computer
onto into a backpack behind you and
there are all these cables and and so it
was a glass so there was excitement and
interest and and the idea and the
imagination for virtual reality has been
around for 30 years or more and probably
more than that in at least in the
science fiction literature literature
I'm sure but it really there's a big
difference between having the idea and
making it a reality
Zakhar Brooklyn and the first wasn't you
like with oculus rift who kicked it off
for ah it was very visible purchased I
think I think that the oculus rift did a
great job of suddenly making people say
hey let's take a look at that is this
the time and when you combine that with
the fact that there's several billion
cell phones out in the world and they
quickly showed with Samsung that you
could do a really satisfying be our
experience you know the cell phone
that's that's suddenly when people
realize hey we might even together could
blue cardboard which has been
distributed by the hundreds of thousands
already yeah to turn the cell phone into
a hand
very cheap but very powerful via device
which everybody can get first from Shawn
hey Eric
what are the main challenges when
working on a VR animation that union
team wouldn't necessarily have
encountered if when you walk in a
traditional animation project I think
it's kind of what we just talked about
you know it's it's about the fact that
the viewer is free to look anywhere they
want if you've got a higher end headset
they can even walk around and explore
the environment so it's really how do
you maintain their attention and their
focus on the things that you'd like them
to to pay attention to and focus on
which is particularly important for
storytelling yeah and if you're going to
have a little stuff going forward I'm
say often the deep discoveries are made
in the decades to come for these new
media right it's probably some twelve
year old kid out there who who will grow
up with virtual reality that will
actually you know transcend anything
anybody's thought of you know change the
world
yeah I can't wait to have also with like
multiplayer games in VR we have joined
experiences my right now asks a question
we have a lot of people we teach program
yeah and sometimes there's a bit of a
confusion what does I need to go to
Pixar in the sled magic or DreamWorks
because I wanna buy creatives and hover
their work so a question is what is the
role of a programmer in an animation
company is an entirely technical or can
it be artistic and what qualifications
for the person have to say to join Bower
well I think the best work environment
in an artistic / technical field is one
where there's a lot of overlap and
there's a lot of communication and you
know programming is a very creative job
I think in you know many applications
but understanding what is needed
creatively from the non programmers and
for the non programmers to understand
what the programmers are talking about
what they explain they're capable of
doing how they might just get these legs
like dorks or sit in the corner and
program and these like it could it be
creative fancily dressed but flick how
do you put it together
well I do think that programmers are
going to stereotype here ya know I think
creative and they should be creative and
the best programmers are creative they
can look at a creative problem and come
back with a programming solution that
will help the artists who achieve what
they need to do and I shouldn't even say
the artist because I think the
programmers at least in our field the
more artistic they are the better
because and the more the artists are
versed in technology the better because
then it that way we're speaking more
closely the same language and so for me
to be able to talk to you know a
programmer about you know an algorithmic
progression or geometric progression in
terms of how something's working in the
program is really helpful that I can
talk that way to them just as it's
helpful that they can talk to me about
what it is we're looking for creatively
and actually understand why a Lyons say
body needs to deform a certain way and
perhaps understand a little bit about
the anatomy of the character and how
that might apply to how they might set
the technical setup of the character to
you know to work so it's the ratio of
creatives and software people in your
company um it's probably about half and
half half and a half okay so that's
pretty good and they're sitting the same
office uh-huh that's pretty pisser
right and it's great because you know
you buy off-the-shelf software where all
the technics technicians and programmers
are somebody else and what do you do if
it's not working but you know I I kind
of you know started out at PDI which was
all in-house software so I knew like
Shawn was the guy that wrote this
program and I could walk over three
cubicles and go Shawn is singing work
and he can sit down oh I know what's
wrong then you go back and then 30
minutes later you go try it now and I
know these is it go to slack and go to
slacken typing it's not working and the
other person might be some by the
planets possibly sleeping there's a lot
of slack going around the office and I'm
thinking you know you're right over
there you could just turn your head and
talk to me never works sometimes I want
to be with the intelligence like
chatbots so just keep the slack on free
run down ask the question first the
question what started your passion for
creating animated movies and how long
did it take you to perfect the skills
you have not to create and
direct-to-video movies well I'm not I'm
haven't perfected it if you're if you
haven't no one has an define your level
at the level or do your MA perfection
well I started
making making films actually as a kid
never thought of it I'd never even
entered my mind that I could do it as a
living and then when I went to to
college I started taking classes in the
film school and was really inspired by
this filmmaker named Stan brackish has
passed away but he's a famous
avant-garde filmmaker of the 20th
century and got me onto my own
filmmaking stuff and so I was making I
was seriously trying to make films
although many of those were very bad
films starting around 1981 or so and so
it took me another 15 years before
anybody offered me a job to direct a
feature film and in that time like I
said I made a lot of bad films I made
some okay films I made some films that
I'm proud of but the only way I think to
really make it in this world
particularly as an artist is to do art
you know and you got to do it and if you
don't if you have a great idea and you
don't do it don't you
then you're not an artist it's a saying
is this something that that every
filmmaker has to go through the 15 years
of mediocre movies to find the arrive at
the point where you get this perfect
touch or is it something that could be
passed on much faster
I think everybody's different you know I
think it's it's a good defined you wanna
see I'm on there's people that that make
amazing films you know in their 20s like
Orson Welles for example and and there's
people they make amazing films is
they're the best never ever make is
their first film and some people would
say that aborts and Welles I actually
happen to love a lot of the other films
that he made in his career but
everybody's different and for me I think
it just took a lot of maturation and and
a lot of stuff that I did that just
didn't come naturally to me that I had
to I had to learn so what but however
long it takes you will never get to the
you will never get there if you don't
start going you know you can't win a
race if you don't start that's so I
always encourage people to just go and
do it you know go to your studio and
make stuff and as soon as camera so
cheap though hunted
it's not cheaper than it used to be when
I was doing it all I had all you had was
a was film you know and that actually
worked well for me because that meant
every because every time you pull the
trigger when you're shooting motion
picture film it's like dollar signs I
really was a kid little camera every
time I click it was one dollar really
think about what it is you're shooting
and it's almost I found that when video
came out it actually almost made it more
difficult because we make film because
you're Tennessee is just to go shoot
everything all day long and then you've
got like you know ten hours of footage
and you're trying to make a five minute
film and like what do I do with all this
I had a friend who had 50,000
point-and-shoot pictures of his daughter
and never look at anything else I've got
a drawer full of videos of my kids and I
haven't looked at him either and now
that I don't even have a device that
will play those videos but I've got to
shoot them off somewhere and pay
somebody bunch of money we are at the
Innovation Center of the world in
Silicon Valley undoubtedly and not the
only one but it's probably most known
one and we had people like Astro Telecom
visit and talked to me at the same stage
in tavar we asked a question about
innovation and he wants to know as a
leader
how can you promote a constantly
innovative environment in your team I
think the best way is to allow people to
participate at every level you know even
Walt Disney said this you know when he
had a story meeting everybody was
invited including his secretary because
he believed that a great idea can come
from anybody and so if you have an
environment where people feel free to
communicate not only with their peers
but with the CEO and where even the you
know the person that stock in the
refrigerator is a part of this is a part
of this team and feels accepted and
feels inside and is and if that person
is confident enough to raise their hand
and say you know what if you did it this
way then you've got an environment that
I think empowers and engenders
innovation because everybody feels like
they have permission it's great
that's that scale to large organizations
as a break point at some point um excuse
me memo of belief it's you know I don't
have a lot of experience I have
one experience and that was a PDI when I
got there there was about 30 people and
then we grew into you know a team of
several hundred people and there's no
doubt that the that the environment and
the tone of the place changed kind of
like you can almost see it like he hits
75 people and then something switches
and suddenly there's not all those
connections because it's just impossible
and I don't have a solution for that
I think I'll discover myself with baobab
is we hopefully continue to grow and and
add people but they but it definitely
changes the equation Kelly wants to know
what is your favorite movie and why well
I have a lot of favorite movies but I
think one of the ones you own of course
but one that I never tire of watching is
a film by um Norman McLaren who worked
for the National Film Board of Canada I
think it was done in the 50s early 60s
and it's called be gone dull care and
it's a direct animated film so that
means he's taken the the strip of clear
leader with the sprocket holes in it and
painted directly onto the film and it's
done to an Oscar Peterson jazz tune and
it's just remarkable and it's beautiful
and it's mesmerizing and I try to watch
it at least a couple times a year you
can find it online I would love to do it
it's on you can find it on YouTube great
and yeah be gone don't care
William wants to know what is the most
challenging thing for a director and
directing a movie well it's always story
it's always still the same yeah 95% of
what I was doing at DreamWorks was story
it doesn't matter how pretty the picture
is if you have a bad story people will
get bored it doesn't matter how cool the
technology is if you don't have some
people want something deeper ultimately
like right now in VR there's a lot of
tech demos out there you know look and
see what we can do this is and it is
it's cool this is amazing we can do this
we can put you on a rollercoaster we can
we can do what anything you can imagine
but there's very few pieces of content
out there that acts
the you know give you a beginning in the
middle and an end and give you something
that actually transcends what you can do
and shows you something that you maybe
couldn't imagine and then suddenly you
see like something beyond that the
medium itself do you think this is these
TV series that are very popular and Game
of Thrones and house of cards dead
medium and making to VR like the weekly
one-hour long I think there's a lot
better chance of that happening than
with with computer animation because
it's a lot easier to get a VR
live-action camera and and set up some
some performance than it is to create a
computer animated piece the difference
is that with computer animation because
we have all the other hooks into things
we can make it very interactive and with
a live-action piece aside from sort of
splitting storylines there's not a lot
you can do with interactivity so like
what you shoot is what is he getting if
you but I think we're gonna see a lot of
VR live-action VR serials kind of Josh
wants to know whether the computer
graphics part is harder in VR than in
regular animation it is harder and
because you don't have this you don't
have eleven Millicent like we might take
two days to render a frame on Madagascar
and now we have eleven millisecond so
it's a lot of frames it's hard to
deliver the same quality and in a really
short amount of time it's it's harder
because you have to have something at a
360-degree world where as you can you
know very explicitly decide decide
what's going to be within that rectangle
of cinema cinematic experience and and
the list just goes on and on but a lot
of it is just pumping all that data
through that tiny little pipe that you
typically have with a phone and even
with the oculus headset or the vive
headset you still have to be careful you
know you can't have an infinite number
of lights you can't have an infinite
number of polygons you know it's fur is
really it's reminds me of the days when
I got involved in computers in the late
eighties early nineties ones like we've
got a job to do fur how do we differ I
have your idea flames smoke claims
things that we take for granted in real
life like clouds and why
really difficult yeah always and
especially so when you have to do it in
11 more seconds minecraft blocks that's
so much easier - exactly
another fun and it's a lesson that
minecraft can still be very compelling
yes in that context yes so can poke them
and go apparently no I just watched a
video though somebody running into the
back of a parked police car while they
were playing you know it's just because
of this dumb game it's funny industry
lawsuits coming up yeah well it closed
with a student question for an anonymous
student is anonymous and he says or
faeces did you learn anything or
everything from a top-notch school or
did you ever try an arrow on your own
account I learned a great deal from my
undergraduate experience and I learned a
great deal from CalArts as well it's a
great opportunity to really focus
yourself but to be a filmmaker and
particular to be a director you have to
go through the world with an open mind
and open eyes and just like I said it's
important to talk to to be able to talk
the language of the programmer you know
for me I need to be able to talk the
language of music with the composer I
need to be able to talk to the animators
about acting I need to be able to talk
to the voice actors about their
performances if I need to talk to the
artists about so it's kind of like one
of those things where you're a jack of
all trades and a master of none and you
try to surround yourself with people
that are better at what they do than you
could ever be and that's the secret key
to success is to find somebody that's
more ambitious than you and become their
part don't learn math just find
something we can do bad for you well
that's part of how it happens you know
somebody's gonna be better you have many
tens of thousands of maybe even more
students watching us around the world
many of them are Bish's to come to
Silicon Valley
what is he wisdom or wisdom for people
that are young but exploring the world
what would it tell me well I think that
you know the world is always changing
and anybody that gets kind of to my age
and Beyond will always say well I'm
but it's a it is a real reality and and
the best way to navigate that is not to
necessarily think that every single
detail of your life has to be planned
out or that that you you have to make
the right choice every step of the way
the best thing is you know it's Joseph
Campbell says it's like just follow your
bliss find the things that that are most
exciting and interesting to you because
then you're gonna do your best work and
you're gonna learn the most because you
you care
mm-hm and and then you might be shooting
for this door at the end of the hallway
and then suddenly you won't even expect
it and this door over here will open up
and they'll go hey you get in here and
they'll drag you in and suddenly you'll
be doing something really exciting that
involves all of these skills that you've
been developing in your life because you
you've been developing from a place of
passion there is such great advice Eric
I want to thank you for coming it's been
an amazing pleasure I'm looking forward
to the release tomorrow I'm your first
customer but I've been a fan of your
world for a long time thanks for coming
thanks it's been a pleasure when I tell
our audience this is our fourth talk
they have a fifth talk coming up I think
on August 25th
we have an entourage Ramon who is a
serial entrepreneur and no for greater
science a technical person come to us
and have the pleasure interviewing him
and so far goodbye Freitas he talks